tom devlin's monster museum in boulder
city offers a living history of
horror cinema his new attraction the
fright zone is
perfect for all of you ghoul lovers jc
fernandez is live with the tale ah
jc is that you
yeah yes this is my this is my friend
kirsten uh zombie woman right here
uh tom devlin's monster museum is
perfect for halloween
and here's the man himself tom devlin
tom how would you describe your museum
and set up to someone
so our place is a place one of a kind
that you can come and see screen used
props like these puppets from the puppet
master series
to uh one of a kind works of art like
the killer clowns from there oh yeah
yeah i saw this movie it's a scary movie
all these movies are scary uh this is
the actual screen user you need these
yourself these are just custom
re-fabbed versions of the clowns and uh
the original heads were made for a mask
company but
that uh these guys right here are one of
a kind let's walk around the corner
because you have you have so much uh
to see here inside your museum and this
is uh the back room here i like i like a
lot because these are kind of the
characters that we're familiar with
right
we have here halloween yeah halloween
michael myers we have the leprechaun
ash from the evil dead uh one of my
personal favorites leatherface right
behind you here
and what's so great about this place it
is so instagram-worthy you can walk
through here you can take pictures
i want to cuz we got jason back here
this is so cool
you come down here you take a picture of
jason it's so so realistic and it's you
post it on instagram it's the perfect
thing
to post within friends
and there's scares that happen inside
the monster meme monster museum as well
is this guy always back here or is he
just kind of here hanging out for me he
is not always back here but
in october after 7 p.m the lights go out
and we
replace some of the displays with live
monsters so the monsters come alive at
our uh nightmare at the monster museum
and my heart is now pounding because of
that guy that's standing back there
scaring me
and what's great too is we have our mask
on you have safety protocols in place as
well
and come back here because we do have
back here this is kind of the wes craven
room every room has a theme
yeah yeah so we have freddy of course
pluto from the hills of eyes and scream
this is all wes craven's work now come
back here this is this museum is
non-stop
every time you come around a corner
there's something new come back this way
lancy come around here
and what room is this back here with
this is our zombie
stephen king room so we represent all
the george romero zombies we bridge the
gap with creep show which stephen king
and
george romero teamed on and then of
course we have tar man behind you from
return of the living dead the greatest
zombie film of all time
now come out through here this is the uh
enter we're going to kind of leave the
uh
monster museum itself and come into the
lobby area when you come inside here
in the lobby you have all kinds of
halloween stuff for sale as well
yeah and then coming up we're going to
head to
the freight zone the fright zone that's
our uh our gallery of fear which is next
door and it is 100
scary halloween walk through love it tom
devlin's monster museum i'm sorry you
guys my heart is racing from that scare
that he had planted there for me but
coming up we're gonna go check out
the fright zone and i'm sure i'm gonna
be scared at some point again we'll send
it back to you guys in the studio
stay strong jc stay strong well